[Laughter]
I'm like the pants in the interwebs
sometimes the memory of what could it is
so much stronger than what actually
happened because the nanny profession
last longer
no we didn't end up together never
change the back edge we change my life
forever
[Laughter]
I of course Ellis
capture the avatar and regain my honor
all day today
civilizer kind of become means increases
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone is Charlie happy
15th anniversary to Avatar The Last
Airbender
so Nickelodeon and the avatar people did
a special 15th anniversary panel
recently so I'll break that down they
talked a lot about what's going on with
the future of Avatar The Last Airbender
and even the idea of more animated
sequels to Avatar The Last Airbender as
in the idea that Legend of Korra was a
sequel to avatar the last airbender
would they ever do more animated series
now it sounds like that might actually
be a reality so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos obviously I'll be doing
videos for the new Netflix avatar the
last airbender series so I will do an
update on what's going on with
production on that during the video too
we'll just break this down top 5 style
so number 5 the actual 15th anniversary
the anniversary itself is for the first
episode that was for February 21st 2005
so Friday was the actual anniversary
that's when this panel was taking place
if you consider yourself an avatar the
last airbender historian then you
probably know that the first episode
isn't the pilot episode technically
there was a test pilot that they did
that they never aired when they did the
first DVD home release of the series
they added the unreleased pilot to that
but a lot of the panel that they did was
dedicated to talking about the origins
of the series everyone from the cast and
crew talking about their favorite
memories making the series especially
Dante Bosco's favorite Zuko moments
favorite Zuko memes like he did the big
Zoot are a poem in the clip that I
attached to the beginning of this if
you're not familiar with the origin of
the series Avatar The Last Airbender
started when Mike and Bryan were coming
off of other animated series they've
been friends for a while but Nickelodeon
asked them to pitch a new series he was
around the very early 2000s like 2000
2001 and we were still in the middle of
the Lord of the Rings trilogy of movies
so because those were the most popular
movies in the world at the time
as Hollywood studios tend to do they
wanted Mike and Bryan to pitch something
that capitalized on something in that
vein very Lord of the Rings the epic
adventure series something with a quest
something that felt huge in scale and
epic but made for children and because
this is Nickelodeon we're talking about
the other major hit that they had at the
time was spongebob spongebob had just
started in 1999 so this is just a couple
years after spongebob had started they
officially pitched the series in early
2001 so that's when it actually got
started it didn't premiere
two thousand five so they spent about
four years developing the series Bryan
Konietzko drew this picture of a
character hurting bison in the sky then
showed the sketch to Mike who was
watching a documentary about explorers
trapped at the South Pole the way that
Bryan described it he said there's this
air guy along with these water people
trapped in a snowy wasteland and maybe
some fire people are pressing down on
them and then they basically pitch that
to Nickelodeon then obviously it evolved
from there into the Avatar series that
we all watched in the episodes if you've
never watched any of the bonus features
from Avatar The Last Airbender book ones
DVD release they have a lot of the
footage of them developing the series in
scenes of them with Sifu ki soo trying
to develop the bending styles so the
actual origin of the series is very well
documented in bonus features the whole
reason why they went with the Eastern
cultural aesthetic overall for the
series was because they grown up loving
classic anime and manga and Miyazaki
films and wanted to try something unique
that hadn't been done on Nickelodeon up
to that point
remember spongebob was Nickelodeon's big
hit at the time the specific series that
most inspired Avatar The Last Airbender
were a cowboy bebop samurai champloo and
fooly cooly number four so as you heard
in the clip at the beginning of this
dante basco
reading the zoo tora poem that he
created a while ago and reciting it for
the anniversary i believe he actually
created a long time ago because he's
been doing conventions for avatar the
last airbender pretty regularly since
the series has ended and he's recited
poems like this in the past like he says
the fans consider me the captain of the
zoo tarah ship but just because they
spent a bunch of time joking and talking
about zoo tourist stuff on the panel
doesn't mean they're gonna radically
alter the plot of the Netflix Avatar The
Last Airbender series the version of
Avatar The Last Airbender that Mike and
Brian are doing for Netflix right now is
just meant to be a live-action version
of the original series if you've ever
watched any of Netflix's original series
most of them are an hour long per
episode in 8 to 13 episodes per season
the most popular ones tend to get 4 to 5
seasons average like stranger things for
instance might go past four seasons but
it could stop at four so four or five
seasons is a good benchmark for the
really big stuff the original Avatar The
Last Airbender series only ran for three
seasons or three books if you want to be
technical but it was only sixty one
half-hour episodes just because
half-hour animation is the industry
standard
so obviously they're gonna have to be
some changes that they make to expand
for the hour-long format but number
three if you guys didn't know there
actually is a lost episode of Avatar The
Last Airbender technically 62 episodes
it's called escape from the spirit world
and it's actually a canonical story that
was made for a video game but it is
canon - the series meant to take place
between the events of book 2 earth after
Azula takes down egg while is in the
Avatar State with her lightning attack
he goes into a very deep slumber that's
where this episode this lost episode
takes place and then before the events
of book 3 pick up the episode is
basically him visiting four of his past
lives to reconnect with them come back
to the world of the living
while also try to avoid code the face
stealer who's trying to steal his face
during the episode number two Dante
Basco has been asked multiple times in
the past few weeks in addition to what
was going on with this 15th anniversary
panel if he's going to be in the new
avatar the last airbender Netflix series
are you gonna star in it are you gonna
play character he's really happy to talk
about it he's been a real bro about it
but of course he's under NDA so he can't
really say anything about it his
official response typically has been
something along the lines of we'll have
to see like kind of winking behind the
camera like yes we all know that I'm
gonna be in this but Netflix will sue me
if I leak the announcement if you're
really frustrated with Netflix not
making any real big news announcements
about what's going on with the new
Netflix avatar the last airbender series
is because they like to sit on news like
that information reveals because they
want to turn that into big marketing
events like when they drop trailers to
create awareness for it create some hype
a lot of people had just hoped that they
would have done something some big
announcement for the avatar anniversary
and yes they are getting ready to start
filming they probably already been
shooting a bunch of test footage and
visit X camera tests like they just
released the Batman teaser trailer which
was basically a camera test of Robert
Pattinson in his new Batman costume
they've been doing that kind of stuff
kind of figuring out what everything is
gonna look like the costumes the
physical world for about the past year
all the story outlines the scripts and
all that started way before that -
initially when they pitched Netflix
about developing the project and they
announced it back in 2018 that's how
long it's been it's been 2018 since they
first announced the project the first
thing they do in situations like that is
develop a story outline then start
writing
Grips then they start figuring out what
everything is gonna look like then they
start casting and shooting because
they're expanding the episodes to the
hour-long format they did say back when
they first announced the series was
going to happen did they'd be using that
extra half-hour to spend more time with
each of the characters more character
development so even though we're getting
live-action versions of the original
episodes there will be a lot of new
material added in that was not in the
original series that they either didn't
have time for because it was half hour
animation or that they were censored and
they weren't allowed to do because it's
Nickelodeon one of the benefits of going
to Netflix is there's no regulation on
censorship or what they can and can't do
they can do pretty much whatever they
want in episodes but probably one of the
coolest things at this 15th anniversary
panel number one WTF was that it was
implied they might also be open to doing
more animated Avatar The Last Airbender
sequels in the future keep in mind this
would be in addition to any live-action
Avatar The Last Airbender stuff they're
doing because it's also implied that if
it's successful Netflix will also want
to do live-action sequels to like do a
live-action of Korra after they're done
doing live-action Aang but I think that
Nickelodeon is really thirsty to
capitalize on the Avatar brand in the
age of streaming networks but usually
situations like that is when they go
back to creators like Mike and Bryan and
say hey you have this beloved series we
think that fans will buy our streaming
service if we release brand-new animated
avatar sequels on it so we'll see if we
hear any news about more animated
sequels I will totally do videos about
that too
let me know in the comments if you have
any special requests for Avatar bonus
videos and everyone post your favorite
memories for the 15th anniversary so
while you wait for everything everyone
click here for all my new avatar the
last airbender Netflix videos and click
here for my brand new Star Wars the
Clone Wars season 7 episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome this is the way
[Music]
you